viescha Presidente Timmerman la la
parola that's a Presidente honorable
members have listened very carefully to
this debate and I'm really excited by
the fact that this Parliament has
expressed such broad support for the
European Green Deal this is a great
start of what is going to be quite a
bumpy road where we will need both
institutions to concentrate on all the
elements that we need to make the Green
Deal work because well let me say here
today I want to congratulate to get a
tool bag
for having been nominated Person of the
Year by Time magazine I think this is a
great sign a great sign that this
generation our kids are leading the way
and as a parent there's nothing more
beautiful that when you see that your
kids are leading the way but that's not
the only reason why I believe we need to
act now
the reason I believe we need to act now
is because the facts are staring us in
the face and I think if you are a
responsible member of parliament if
you're in the responsible position in
the Commission if you're a citizen if
you're a parent you do not have the
luxury to ignore the facts look at
what's happening in Greenland look at
what's happening globally with our
climate look at the desertification look
at the erratic weather look at the
people suffering because of this erratic
weather across Europe look at what's
happening to a biodiversity as we speak
we do not have the luxury to ignore this
anymore and look at another thing that's
happening we are in the middle of the
fourth Industrial Revolution that is
going to change our economy our industry
whether we like it or not whether we act
or not so the question we have to face
today as Europeans is this are we going
to try and be masters of this momentous
change of this paradigm shift or are we
just going to let it happen and then
others will be the masters of it and we
can just be the subjects of what others
will decide this is the fundamental
question we have to answer and the Green
Deal is not a blueprint it's a road map
it's an extended open hand to you and to
all the stakeholders whether it's
businesses whether it's NGOs whether
it's trade unions whether it's citizens
whether it's cities whether it's regions
to be part of a discussion of how we are
going to reorganize our society in a
just way so that it reflects the values
we want to stand for and we need to do
this because Mother Earth is fed up with
this behavior and you know she was able
to exist for millennia without human
beings she will be able to exist for
other millennia without human beings we
better make sure we create an existence
in balance with her so that we can
continue exist as human beings for
millennia and this is the responsibility
we have before our kids but let me make
a point because it was said often this
is costly yes but don't forget what the
cost is of not acting we see it every
day it was also said we have to be sure
we take the right decisions yes that is
why every proposal the commission is
going to put on the table will be
assessed for impact impact assessment
will be an essential element of our
analysis but we will do this in a very
very speedy and comprehensive way for
instance to determine exactly what the
reduction by 2030 should be from 50 to
minus 55 percent we want to have an
impact assessment on that but we want to
be ready with that impact assessment
in the summer next year so that the
European Union is extremely well
prepared with a climate law for cop 26
in Glasgow so that we can lead the way I
bring back a message from Madrid the cop
where I'm going to go back and present
the Green Deal tomorrow message is this
we need European leadership the message
is also this some of us are insecure
what we should do but if Europe leads we
might go in the same direction I had
meetings with ministers for many
countries saying climate neutrality by
2050 is a good idea we might do the same
way with the Chinese we're in the debate
are we going to have collective global
leadership on this yes or no we need to
work on that because if we do it
together the impact will be much bigger
but at the end of the day it is very
important that this Parliament take this
into hand and make sure that Parliament
has a leading role together with the
Commission to convince our Member States
and Council to do the right thing and if
we begin by enshrining in law that 2050
2050 Europe will be climate neutral then
we can take steps back until today and
just chart the map that we need to get
there and then we will discuss the
measures we will need to take whether
it's on ETS whether it's on emissions
whether it's on taxation whether it's on
all sorts of other measures to make our
industry circular to make sure that
there are jobs in this new economy but
finally I want to add one thing which is
very very important you know the biggest
risk here I see is that those who are
most vulnerable in climate change see
themselves also as most vulnerable in
the answer to climate change so that
they start resisting the Green Deal
because they feel that they are
vulnerable and at the end of the day if
they resist the Green Deal and it's they
stop it they will be the first victims
of the consequences of not doing the
right thing so that's why and this is a
fundamental point
if this is not a social Green Deal the
Green Deal will not happen if this is
not a Green Deal where the most
vulnerable regions in Europe coal mining
regions and others do not see solidarity
from other parts of Europe it will not
happen so we need a level of solidarity
with vulnerable individuals and
vulnerable regions to make sure the
Green Deal can be delivered for all our
citizens and at the end because mr. long
a quoted man on the moon so I of coffee
ously thought of the famous moon speech
by JFK and let me just amend it slightly
and end with that we choose to go to the
moon in this case we choose to go for
climate neutrality in 2050 and do the
other things not because they are easy
but because they are hard because that
goal will serve to organize and measure
the best of our energies and skills
because that challenge is one that we
are willing to accept one we are
unwilling to postpone and one which we
intend to win
Thank You Grazia Grazia presidented
immerman grazie a tutti parent caller
okay so intervene UT la discusión
accuser la votación Isis Valle Jarrod
want a lot or not a DJ naio uno el
proceso verb aller Sarasota Portola
privation Adele parlamento la próxima C
ruta de Hierro entero terrassa Sione del
parlamento Europa Grazia